the kennedy center honors are back in
full swing the awards for artistic
excellence were presented last night in
washington after changes and delays to
last year's plans because of the
pandemic president biden joined the
celebration after former president trump
skipped the ceremony for all four years
in the white house last night's honorees
included get this bette midler motown
founder barry gordy and folk music
legend joni mitchell
i want to officially welcome everybody
back to the kennedy center
the 44th kennedy center honors return to
traditions this year
to honor artists for their contributions
to american culture for any mood or
emotional crossroad where you might find
yourself
there's a joni mitchell song the evening
featured tributes to singer-songwriter
joni mitchell
[Music]
and also honored opera singer justino
diaz
it is for no single performance
but for the collective body of his
staggering career that we honor justino
tonight and saturday night live creator
lorne michaels was celebrated and
roasted by current and former snl cast
members this kennedy center honor is a
long time coming for lauren since he
said he would only accept it when j.lo
and ben got
[Music]
legendary stage and screen icon bette
midler is another one of this year's
honorees she can make us laugh and cry
even at the same time
and that is the mark of an artist
of the highest caliber songwriter and
record producer barry gordy who founded
the motown record label was also honored
[Music]
with performances by stevie wonder that
had the opera house in a standing
ovation
you can watch the 44th annual kennedy
center honors december 22nd at 9 pm 8
central right here on cbs looked like a
good time was had by always a good show
always
just when you think they can't find
somebody else to add to the class they
always come up with somebody and it's
always fantastic how good did stevie
like oh stevie looks everybody was
grooving everybody was groovy